there's this absolute lunatic Christian
named Jim Baker he's a televangelist he
was previously convicted of actual fraud
served time in prison he's known for
selling those long term food buckets
Christian food storage as I call it you
can get you know a thousand servings of
dehydrated mashed potatoes for the
apocalypse that sort of thing he has now
been ordered by the New York Attorney
General to stop selling a fake virus
cure
he's been touting this thing called
silver solution and he brought on a
guest
Cheryl Selman who's about as much of a
lunatic as Jim Baker check out the
conversation they had we're going to
have to really break this down piece by
piece because it's a clinic and
disinformation and pseudoscience and
it's dangerous pseudoscience at bat
let's get into clip number one God gave
us this product yeah I believe yes how
many did we go out acai was he gave this
to us about 10 12 years ago and we have
it at our home we have it in cases so
this is already whacked okay he believes
God gave them the product of silver
solution why wouldn't God just prevent
the conditions that silver solutions
supposedly treats and cures right like
why go through the trouble God's a busy
guy or gal if they exist why would God
first create all sorts of conditions
that require treatment then create
silver solution to cure them it's much
simpler just don't require the silver
solution by not creating the conditions
that supposedly Jim Baker says it treats
its already bonkers
let's continue we use it all the time I
have this and I mean I don't think I
don't made it without silver it for my
throat in all that absolutely as I've
had this and this is amazing why
whatever so would you recommend is a
doctor people to have silver in their
house for it without silver okay so now
he goes to his doctor doctor do we want
silver oh yes Jim we want silver we need
silver Cheryl Selman the doctor is
what's called an ND that's a
naturopathic doctor she's not a medical
doctor now
I'm not interested in debating the
merits of naturopathy with you here but
the amount of pseudoscience that
naturopathy is just filled up with and
perpetuates is stunning and he's being
dishonest by saying doctor because a
normal person is going to say they're
talking about curing illness and he's
referring to her as doctor she must have
some kind of actual medical credentials
no we're talking about a naturopath here
let's keep going
here's where they start getting into
viruses listen very carefully to the
language that they use now so many
reasons never never you know this is a
staple top yes stated I think this is a
staple for your family yes and we can
talk more about it maybe we have more
time yeah I got time all I can say is
that it has been proven by the
government that it has the ability to
kill every pathogen it has ever been
tested on including SARS and HIV proven
by the government that it has the
ability to kill every pathogen it has
ever been tested on including SARS and
HIV proven by the government well proven
by which government what do you mean by
proven what do you mean it kills
pathogens there are lots of so-called
pathogens that you can put in a petri
dish where they are relatively benign
and you can take many substances you can
dump bleach on to it you can I mean
listen you can probably find pathogens
that Gatorade will kill in a petri dish
if you leave it in there for hours but
it's meaningless commentary unless you
actually know the details of what
they're suggesting if they aren't total
lies which obviously they are and then
now they get to what is really the key
part this influenza that is now circling
the goal you're saying that Silver's
solution would be effective well let's
say it hasn't been tested on this strain
of the corona virus but it's been tested
on other strange route of the corona
virus and a half
been able to eliminate it within 12
hours yeah
totally dominated kills it and
deactivates it yeah oh so alright so it
hasn't been tested on this strain of the
virus oh I see well tell me more well it
has eliminated other strains of
coronavirus no well actually it has
killed other strains no it has
deactivated other strains get off the TV
this is when you know that this is BS it
killed the virus it eliminated it it
deactivated it it this is meaningless
dangerous drivel that can potentially
kill people and then they do their
normal thing which is they throw an O it
also boosts your immune system any time
you hear that that's a red flag and then
it boosts your immune system so then you
can support the recovery because when
you kill the virus then the immune
system comes into action to clear it out
so you want a vibrant immune system as
well as an ability to deactivate these
viruses that's so oh so ok so you kill
the virus with the silver and then that
same silver will boost your immune
system which deactivates the virus this
should be criminal now if you've not
heard about the silver stuff before
there's this whole world of what's
called colloidal silver and not only
does colloidal silver not do any of the
things they say it doesn't treat any
disease it doesn't treat any symptom it
can actually be dangerous when you take
colloidal silver it can cause you to not
absorb actual medications that you're
taking real ones like antibiotics it can
also start to build up in your skin
tissue and you can start to turn like a
bluish gray hue because of the
consumption of silver and it does
nothing for you it's not a necessary
mineral it's not a dietary supplement
it's ridiculous and it can harm you talk
about preying on people worried about
getting sick these lunatic
right-wing evangelical Christian shows
much like Fox News have
disproportionately older audiences who
are most
risk to all viruses flu etc as well as
Cova 19 which is going on this is
horrible these are terrible people this
should be criminal it should be criminal
to do what it is that they are doing
what if you could read ten books in just
one sitting that's exactly what one of
my favorite apps lets you do it's called
blinka Stan what they do is take
thousands of popular nonfiction books
they condense them down into text or
audio that you can consume in 15 minutes
blinka snakes sure that you're getting
all of the important core insights from
each book so it's perfect for exploring
a book you otherwise wouldn't have time
for there's a full book you're thinking
about buying you can use blink Asst to
get a sample first just think how much
you can enrich yourself by being able to
soak up an entire nonfiction book in
just 15 minutes
I recently checked out the book podcast
marketing strategy by Daniel rolls and
Ciaran Rogers and so useful so
particularly applicable to what I'm
doing really recommended blink east has
books on politics philosophy science
they have 27 different nonfiction
categories and a subscription is only
about eight bucks a month and you get
the entire library but you can try it
totally free and get 25% off a
subscription when you go to blink accom
slash Pakman I've put the link right
underneath this video